[Aplausos]
voy a ser no estás durmiendo pasa si
verdad
hoy me acuerdo que a mí me marcaron y me
dicen
oye jiménez cuando mister y jimena
primero que a extenso es formal es serio
porque pues yo soy y minami la gente me
se elimina su misión oye jimena pues
basta hablar de la felicidad y yo
aristóteles y yo es y yo estoy de
felicidad encantado simplemente llegar
aquí y decirles es más esto igual la
felicidad somos un mundo feliz pero
realmente no existe una forma o una
fórmula
sea igual a la felicidad
yo podría decirte que esta felicidad
se durmió
alguien le puede dar felicidad la
familia te puede dar felicidad tu
trabajo tus amigos lo que quieras pero
si yo te digo a mí me da felicidad
brindar amor dice que no nos funciona lo
mismo y la fórmula no puede ser la misma
porque somos totalmente diferentes a lo
largo de la vida
nosotros vamos aprendiendo con
experiencias fracasos pues todo a base
de araxos prácticamente pero vamos
creando nuestra propia fórmula a mí lo
que me sirve a lo mejor no te sirve a ti
o en existir tips pueden existir
consejos una frase motivacional bueno
mejor le funciona nada más a una persona
en específico entonces a lo largo de la
vida cada quien va creando su fórmula
que sea correcta o incorrecta
simplemente es perfecta para cada quien
la felicidad si es posible pero no es
del nacimiento sea imagínense que estás
en el hospital teniendo al bebé así que
sale el bebé y no es como que hay nombre
que feliz va a ser este niño que va a
rara y no es como que va a salir otro
bebé y hay no para que a margarito pobre
usted toda la vida
creo que imagínate si eso pasara creo
que yo hubiéramos mandado a todos los
amargados a marte y estaríamos pura
gente feliz y estaríamos y tenemos que
la gente todo estaría positivo en esta
vida y creo que yo a los 20 8 años ya
está peludita decidí ser feliz y no es
que no es que era una persona amargada
de mí que estaba llorando por la vida
tampoco pero yo era mi peor enemigo yo
me la pasaba diciendo que no es que sea
esta a sainz o es que ahora me viene el
espejo y veía puras cosas negativas se
los juro yo que me criticaba
no les pasa que tienen a un amigo que
tienen a una persona de tu familia a la
vecina la tía la tía plática que es una
persona que se queja de mucho alguien de
tu oficina que se queja de todo de ahí
no el lunes hay no ya me habló mi jefe
no red nombres que esto si engorda
verdad no pues hay gente que realmente
es así todo el tiempo es gente que se
queja qué pasa pues que te vas alejando
la verdad está rodeada de gente así nos
da como ue busca también como que es ya
para leer también hago el de ratitos
pero no todo el tiempo y eso me pasó
conmigo me escuchaba y ahí no qué
flojera pararme no qué flojera yo no sé
de dónde qué mal me veo te dije
la verdad es flojera que pasa que yo
tome la visión y me di cuenta que
solamente yo decido ser feliz yo tomo la
decisión si me quedó acostada yo tomo la
decisión si son ríos si no son río y que
hice fue pedir ayuda
ayuda necesito ser feliz no pero
realmente pues que así así todavía que
estaba en una depresión si sabía que no
me quería parar de mi cama si sabía que
algo está pasando yo pido ayuda y me
internaron en el hospital siquiátrico
tranquilos pero me internaron en una
clínica de trastorno alimenticio yo
estuve muy grave y puse en base a eso
pues empecé a tener muchas con muchos
problemas pido ayuda y la verdad fue lo
mejor que puede o sea la décima mejor
decisión de mi vida y ahí es cuando digo
todo vale la pena tomé la decisión de
ser feliz a partir de ahí
todos los problemas tienen solo todos
los problemas sea grande sea chiquito
sea lo que sea todo tiene solución a lo
mejor uno se tardan más otros se tardan
menos paciencia obvio pero todos los
días de nuestras vidas
malas noticias siempre que si el
gobierno que si la economía la
contaminación con la vecina que si
mueves el carro que si la música que
siempre hay malas noticias todo el
tiempo y nosotros tenemos el poder de
decir con que me voy a quedar con lo que
me aporta con lo que no me aporta
y hoy en día está un poco más fácil
porque nosotros cuando tú abres tu
celular tú estás viendo lo que tú
quisiste ver lo que sigues
si algo no te aporta si algo te hace
sentir feo si una persona te molesta
nadie te nadie se da cuenta nadie te
dice nada no importa simplemente tú
decides qué quieres ver es el chip yo
por ejemplo
hay dos opciones en esta vida ser feliz
o ser una persona infeliz
qué decides tú yo por ejemplo puedo
decirte no yo soy una persona feliz y
sale la persona amargada que vos claro
claro que tú tienes esto y es que tú
haces esto y es que hacerlo otro nobel
yo no yo no tengo eso y no me refiero
material no material dinero no dinero
pero hay gente dice es que cómo puedo
ser feliz si es que le provee si es que
ya no me queda mi pantalón si es que no
puedo ser feliz
obviamente hay situaciones en la vida
hay peros hay obstáculos hay mil cosas
pero no definen tu felicidad tú pues una
persona feliz y estar viviendo un
momento triste en tu vida pero no te
define como tal yo por ejemplo soy una
persona una figura pública pero soy más
persona que pública yo la verdad yo me
levanto me levanto triste me levanto
enojada lo que la mayoría no saben de la
gente que me sigue en instagram
soy madura no lo sé pero yo me levanto y
parece que estoy de buenas yo me levanto
de un amargue soy soy 0 morning persona
yo no me la van buenas pero qué pasa que
yo digo haber cometido acostada mezcla
amargada no me baño apesto todo el día
yo tengo que cambiar el chip yo me
levanté digo a ver pues me voy a bañar
quiero bailar yo pongo música a todas
millones pongo música pues para echarle
ganas si no puedo nuevo reportar en
redes hasta las tres de la tarde hola
buenos días entonces así que no no creo
que esté padre yo la verdad puedo decir
que tengo gracias de dios el poder no sé
si podés entre comillas o como se pueda
decir pero tengo el poder de transmitir
sonrisas carcajadas
cosas positivas a mí me llegan por
ejemplo hace tres días está en mi casa y
xaki x ahí a la tienda y se acerca una
chava y me abraza pero tipo de la nada
llegó me abrazó y me dice estás
bendecida y yo dios sea
y yo
y yo ahí se los juro dije estoy
iluminada ya me fui me caí en la
banqueta y no me di cuenta al ocaso yo
dije ay pues muchas gracias estoy viva
que existe y me dice me acabo de
divorciar y eres la única persona que me
ha ayudado en este proceso y yo dije
segura o estás contenta porque te digo
si esto a lo mejor yo lo quería sobre tu
vida no pero realmente me dice me
levantaba y buscaba tus historias yo así
que por qué no se ha levantado yo no
estoy a dormir pero no me decía yo te
gustaba y decía es que qué padre está
feliz y yo dos veces a ideas que no pero
pues bueno le echo ganitas y luego a
veces leo mis mensajes
una vez tocó uno que me marcó demasiado
decía limina pero tipo no sé por qué lo
abrí y apenas nada más decía mina y yo
qué pasó
y me dice ayer se murió mi mamá
y yo la verdad que fría aunque no sabía
por qué me lo estaba escribiendo que
quería que contestara y me pone y me
acabas de hacer reír y yo
lo siento mucho pero qué bueno leer esto
y ahí cuando estaba leyendo este mensaje
me di cuenta esa persona es una persona
feliz está pasando una situación en su
vida que le duele está triste a lo mejor
me escribió esto y se puso a llorar pero
es una persona que está feliz no es como
que la felicidad dice borrón y cuenta
nueva porque estás llorando no o sea es
un ratito que lo puedes vivir y lo
puedes sentir
yo por ejemplo hay muchas muchas veces
que la verdad todos nosotros somos
dramáticos noveleros y dicen que no está
haciendo muy novelero porque todos somos
protagonistas de nuestra novela
what's up si no te ponen la pocita
felices tipo de no está amargada o no
está contenta y eso pasa mucho que por
ejemplo tú le pones a tu amiga hoy amiga
te necesito me urge quiero hablar
contigo y no te contesta díaz y tú ni
era mi amiga no sé ni por qué él escribí
el hecho de chiquita luego que ella me
robaba el lonche entonces empiezas a
hacerte una novela cuando tu amiga está
en disney y su papá no le pagó el
internet nunca llegó tu mensaje entonces
creo que ese tipo de novela yo siempre
digo habla las cosas o sea pregunta yo
no me invitaron una vez una piñata ahí
fue cuando me dije o sea soy directo por
una novela o sea en canal bien y yo no
me invitan a la piñata y yo mami es que
no me invitaron el lápiz cierta si te
estás riendo o estás llorando y yo pues
es que seguro no invitaron porque estoy
gordita
y yo me quedé me río sola y yo no sé
cómo que van a confundir con la piñata
que no le invite no hayan porque le
pueden pegar
qué tiene que ver nadie lo pensó nadie
lo dijo nadie no no sé tema simplemente
yo era la única que estaba pensando eso
y fue un novelón que pasó que amiga
porque no me invita este un amigo no
quise yo aunque
pues qué bueno me da gusto
y yo como siempre dicho la verdad el
guardar rencor o estar enojada con
alguien no sé si te pasa te peleas con
tu amiga con tu jefe con quien tú
quieras sales de ahí y estás cargando un
costal de papas realmente pesa no das tu
cien y en el trabajo ni en la oficina es
lo mismo pero de trabajo oficina en tu
casa en el gimnasio o sea estás pensando
en eso y duro y dalí duro y darle
pensando en eso que la neta yo siempre
evitó pedir perdón nos cuesta a muchos
por orgullo por ego por equis o ye razón
nos cuesta pedir perdón y a veces dices
pues es que él fue el que me gritó
y yo es que nos de perdón que tú me
gritas te pues obviamente no pero es
como soltar este problema ya no quede en
ti que esa angustia que tú tienes no
quede en ti
el vivir intensamente se escucha muy
trillado cuando te dicen vive como si
fuera el último día de tu vida nos
escucha trillado pero realmente es
verdad nos importa demasiado el qué
dirán
el famoso qué dirán a mí al principio
antes dedicarme cien por ciento a las
redes sociales me importaba
me levantaba bailaba y yo ay no da la
gana que van a decir y yo funcionario
sabía nada
aquí se subió a la red y no pasa nada
hoy en día es pasar me vale antes me
levantaba me maquillaba así natural luz
para que no se da cuenta y me graba como
semana va a levantar y ahorita me vale 3
cornetas y me levanto no pasa
absolutamente nada
si no hablarán de ti si hay un ente un
árbol me doblé a ti pues que mejor
siempre siempre dicen es que la mala
publicidad no es mala al contrario es
envidia que hablen mientras la araña
envidiosa
el hablar de ti lo hagas bien no lo
hagas mal todo el mundo va a hablar no
es imposible que le caigas bien a todo
el mundo es imposible a mí hay gente
dice es que padre mechanism asia o bien
a todo el mundo yo te próximos el lugar
por roble lo mejor que no y más porque
hay gente que le molesta que yo me
levanté bailando hay gente que se va
pero lo mejor el siguiente día pues se
levantan de buenas todo mundo nos
levantamos bien y aves andamos mal y no
pasa nada se vale
nosotros somos nuestro peor enemigo no
saboteamos nos ponemos límites decimos
no puedo no quiero para que intento
y si nosotros somos nuestro peor enemigo
porque pensamos que no podemos y todavía
ni lo intentamos
o sea realmente todos las todas las
personas que están aquí se dedican o
estudian lo que aman
están amargados están tristes también de
progresivo y hacemos no realmente mi
pregunta es porque si tu papá es
arquitecto no tienes que hacerlo si tu
mamá es doctora no tienes que hacerlo
somos la misma diferentes personas creo
que yo también empecé a ser feliz cuando
encontré lo que me apasiona me di cuenta
que soy o fluyo no sabes ni pienso las
cosas simplemente las hago porque me
divierto soy soy una persona realmente
feliz a ese también se amargada
pregúntele a mi esposo me sangraba te
graba te ahorita
y yo tú me graba si te quemo
si hace las cosas con amor te van a
salir perfectas me siento ya aristóteles
ahora si van a salir perfectas hoy si
les puedo decir soy una persona feliz me
siento plena estoy haciendo lo que me
encanta y esa es mi recomendación hacia
ustedes haz lo que te dé paz lo que te
haga feliz
sin perjudicar a nadie no te metas con
nadie me gusta saber los de al lado no
te compares eres una persona única eres
una persona especial y nunca vas a poder
estar igual que nadie ni arriba ni abajo
ni nadie simplemente sé tú y como diría
chaplin la primera obligación de todo
ser humano es ser feliz y la segunda es
hacer feliz a los demás y tú eres feliz
muchas gracias yo soy primera memoria
[Aplausos]